hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his discussion of Justice in book 1
of on duties this book of stoic ethics
Cicero is going to spend a little bit of
time discussing what we might call Just
War theory in a very early state he's
talking about how people ought to behave
during wartime towards their enemies can
they do whatever they want or are there
certain limits if they want to be just
how do they have to behave not only in
relation to their own people but in
relation to those who they're they're
fighting against and this is a very
vital question very timely even in our
own era there's much discussion about
how we should treat enemy combatants do
they actually have rights that we have
to respect is it okay for us to engage
in whatever deception or destruction we
wish in in dealing with enemy States or
organizations or populations or do we
have to observe certain limits if we
want to look at ourselves as actually
having justice on our side now Cicero
himself is using a lot of examples from
Roman history and this is something that
the Romans gave quite a bit of thought
to they weren't necessarily Stoics the
ones who say kept their word to the
enemy it was it was part of you could
say a developing Roman character but the
Stoics themselves also had some pretty
strong opinions on this and so those are
kind of dovetailing together in a new
synthesis in what Cicero has to tell us
here which is going to be very
influential on considerations of justice
in wartime for people coming after
Cicero as well so he says in the case of
a state in its external relations in in
relation to other states and the people
belonging to those states the rights of
war must be strictly observed and here
he talks about and this is coming from
I think from the Stoics how should we
settle conflicts what are our options
when it comes to dealing with with
issues that people can't agree on like
for example who should be able to graze
their cattle in which places or which
territory belongs to which group or how
should commerce be going on or whether
an offense has taken place by members of
one group against members of another
group and how that should be addressed
or who should be dominating the
Mediterranean Sea right
all of those are our issues of dispute
so how do we settle conflicts Cicero
says there's really two ways two
fundamental ways one is through
discussion through you know going to the
other side and saying listen we want to
talk this out we don't agree about this
we're not going to like just give in but
we want to be rational we want to be
reasonable what what do you think
and that's often quite possible the
other way is by physical force by by you
know aggression you could say and he
says that discussion is characteristic
of human beings so by the time that we
get to using physical force there's
already some problems in in how we're
dealing with things things have already
gone off the rails humanly speaking he
says that you know dealing with things
just by force is characteristic of brute
animals but we do find ourselves
sometimes having to he says resort to
that so we resort to force
only in case that we may not avail
ourselves of discussion so what does
this mean
what is the upshot of this first we have
to actually try to engage in some sort
of diplomacy some some sort of
discussion now that may not be possible
in every case we don't know somebody's
language we have to act very quickly but
you know this place is a burden upon one
you can't just go into a country and
start saying all right let's start
killing everybody here
and that's a okay because they're
different than us and obviously they
don't want us being here and we want to
be here that would be totally unjust
from Cicero's perspective why do we go
to war this is another key point should
we be going to war as he's going to talk
about later on for glory
oh maybe to get you know slaves to get
people under us to crush other people to
to indulge our aggressive instincts
Cicero says the only reason that a
country ought to be going to war is for
the goal of what comes after the war
that is to live in peace notice there's
two conditions here to live in peace
have peace restored not to just be in
war for its own sake and to live in
peace unharmed in some cases it may be
impossible given certain types of
aggression to live in peace with those
people unharmed a prime example of this
would be the battles between Rome and
Carthage the Romans and the
Carthaginians saw each other as rivals
one of them was going to have to
dominate the other one was going to have
to give in and they fought you know a
war essentially to the bitter end and
Carthage was indeed as the elder Cato
had called for destroyed in the process
but Carthage attempted to subjugate Rome
as well and it actually looked pretty
pretty bad forum for quite a while
during the Carthaginian Wars in part
because of Hannibal so the reason for
going to war lies outside of war war is
not something to pursue for its own sake
it requires a justification it requires
you can say an exit strategy or a
reconstruction strategy you have to be
thinking about the piece that is going
to come so that's another really key
aspect now there's there's a number of
things that that Cicero tells us about
how what we might call civilized or
humane people would actually wage war
because they do
in fact have to wage war he is writing
as Roman the Romans were fighting all
the time with different people's there
they're very expansion to become an
empire required a lot of wars but there
are certain conditions that are supposed
to be observed and sometimes to be sure
the Romans didn't observe these as a
matter of fact Cicero sort of speculates
about you know I understand why we had
to destroy Carthage but why did we have
to destroy Corinth couldn't we have
spared them and he comes up with a
justification as an example it seems
like they are on some really good trade
routes and they probably would have
risen up to become a major power again
and tried to attack us so that's
probably why they destroyed Corinth but
what are some of these these ideas about
how we ought to behave so one of the key
things is he says we have to spare
enemies once we actually win that's what
we lose we're screwed and there you know
there is no worrying about what we do
after that but if we win then we have to
spare enemies spare enemies of certain
sorts enemies who are not barbarous or
bloodthirsty but enemies who are not
cruel is another way to put it
qui known crudités and bellow known in
Manas for those who are not inhumane
those who are not cruel those who are
not just engaging in want and aggression
for its own sake if we can say that that
is the case then we don't have to spare
them then we treat them as dangerous
beasts who cannot you know be permitted
to continue on but if they're not that
way then we shouldn't allow our our own
cruelty our own bellicosity our own
passions to tell us let's let's do
damage to them that would be wrong what
else those who surrender have to
actually be protected it's not enough
just to spare them when they become our
dependence we have to take care of them
think about what this would mean in
terms of you know taking people prisoner
in our own time
that means that we become responsible
for them we become responsible for their
safety their security their human rights
this is a very important doctrine sister
Oh actually you know stresses this quite
quite strongly he says that we not only
must be show consideration for those
whom we have conquered we also must
ensure protection to those even though
the battering ram is hammered at their
walls and he gives some examples of this
he says among our countrymen they this
has been followed so closely that those
who have given promise of protection
estates or nations subdued and war
become after the custom of our
forefathers the patrons of those states
the people who are become their
protector their mentor their guider to
lead them into the the new peace that is
supposed to be taking place what else
war has to be declared there has to be a
number of conditions met he says says
this is actually in the the code of the
Roman people and this is a religious
requirement he says no war is just
unless it is entered on after an
official demand for satisfaction has
been submitted or warning has been given
in a formal declaration made so this
rules out things like a preemptive
strike saying well I think that they're
probably going to attack us
so let's go attack them first let's go
destroy their country there has to be a
cause for war you have to actually
submit to somebody and say listen you
know you got to change things here
you've got to make satisfaction or we're
going to war and you know you can give
them a certain amount of time to comply
and you can you know lay down conditions
so they can't have an HA but that is a
requirement if that's not met then it's
not a just war according to Cicero what
else
this is a really tough one promises to
enemies must be kept if you make a
promise even even at the time that
you're fighting to an enemy Cicero says
that you would need to keep that that
promise keeping is an integral part of
justice and you know if you make a
promise like that you probably shouldn't
make promises that's right but if you do
then you you actually need to keep them
and he gives you a few examples of this
he says if under stress of circumstances
individuals have made any promise to the
enemy they're bound to keep their word
even then he uses examples of when
you're a prisoner right in the First
Punic War Regulus has taken prisoner
he's sent to Rome on parole to negotiate
an exchange of prisoners he he made a
motion in the Senate the prisoners would
not be restored in the second place and
his relatives and friends would have
kept him back he chose to return to
death by the hands of the Carthaginians
he in fact fulfilled his his promise
that he had made another issue that that
comes up as well is he brings up the
example of pirates pirates was one of
the you could say great enemies of Rome
Pyrus was the king of Epirus which was
rising as a power in what is nowadays
part of Yugoslavia now is just you know
part of that that whole region there and
a purist was fighting pretty pretty well
against the Romans he mentions a
deserter who comes in and says I can
poison Pyrus the king and the Romans say
no we're not going to go for that so
there's certain limits on on what you're
allowed to do in terms of the weapons
that you use the strategies that you use
it has to be in some respect aboveboard
now one of the key issues that he does
make a distinction about is what you're
fighting the war for so all of this has
been talking about what we could call
wars of survival where you there is a
real risk that your country could be
destroyed
you could lose that you could become
part of a different Empire or you know
some other Commonwealth or just
destroyed wiped off the map altogether
killed subjugated sold into slavery
all of these strictures apply in that
case it's also possible to engage in
Wars for as he says instead of survival
glory or we might say leadership
hegemony supremacy as how its translated
here being in charge and some of the
wars that the Romans were fighting were
in fact Wars of supremacy who's going to
dominate Italy will it be the Romans or
the say binds or the Veloz key or these
other peoples and they conquered them
cicero goes so far as to say listen all
of these strictures that apply to wars
of survival
they apply even more to wars of glory if
you're gonna declare war just to try to
expand your territory a mess around you
really need to follow these these rules
you really need to make sure that you
are being completely just or what you're
doing is just naked aggression and the
other people could I think look at it
justly as a war of survival and and you
know think that they're completely just
and acting the same way against you
notice too that there there is no
requirement of complete reciprocity here
you don't you know you don't decide
whether you're going to like keep a
promise or declare war based on whether
those other people who may be in fact
barb you know barbaric uncivilized you
know nefarious or anything like that
they they may not follow that but
Cicero's saying if we're going to be a
civilized country we have to follow
these rules and those are in fact duties
towards both the enemy state and enemy
people in war
you